في واضح النهار يفند المشهد روايه
الاحتلال الذي اتهم عمار مفلح بمحاولته
تنفيذ عمليه طعام حاول جندي اعتقال عمار
بالقوه امسك عمار بندقيه الجندي والقاها
على الارض استنى الجندي سلاحا اخر
[موسيقى]
ترك جنود الاحتلال عمار ينزف اكثر من 50
دقيقه على الشارع الرئيسي في بلده حواره
جنوب نابلس كان عمار وهو من بلده اوصرين
القريبه يستعده هو والعائله لاقامه حفلا
لاستقبال سامر الشقيق الاكبر الذي سيخرج
من سجون الاحتلال بعد شهر
الام المكلومه التي لم تستوعب ما حدث
لابنها لا مطلب لها الا بتسليم الاحتلال
جثمانه الذي يحتجزه انقهرت انقهرت تتقطع
قلبي عليه يوم انهم طخوه
يعني دافع عن حاله اكثر اجت اثرت يوم طخوا
في سرهمتني
الكاميرات دفع مسؤولين دوليين للاذانه
والمطالبه بالمحاسبه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
اعرب عن قلقه من تصاعد العنف واكد في بيان
ان قتل الاحتلال 10 فلسطينيه خلال اثنتين
وسبعين ساعه يعكس استخدامه قوه الامن
الاسرائيليه القوه المميته وطلب بالتحقيق
وضمان المسائله اما المبعوث الاممي لعمليه
السلام في الشرق الاوسط فقد ادانا في
تغريده له قتل الفلسطيني عمار مفلح على يد
جندي اسرائيلي في حواره ودعى الى اجراء
تحقيقا فوري ومحاسبه الجنى
من جانبها اكدت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه في
بيان ان المشهد الدامي لاعدام الشاب مفلح
يعكس الارهاب المنظمه في عمليات القتل
سواء على المستوى الدولي او سواء المستوى
المحلي بهذا المعنى لن تكون هذه الحوادث
تتكرر بشكل يومي في نابلس وفي جنين وفي
رام الله وفي كل مكان الان اصبح الفلسطيني
هو موضوع قتل ليس اقل ولا اكثر في السياسه
الاسرائيليه الرسميه
منذ بدايه العام الحالي قتل الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اكثر من 2001 11 فلسطينيه
وتحتجز جثامين 119 شهيدا في ثلاجات
الاحتلال
لمجرد الاشتباه في تشكيل خطر قد لا يتوانى
جندي الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عن اطلاق الرصاص
على اي فلسطين انه واقع الحال خلال الايام
الاخيره بشكل خاص وطيله هذا العام الذي
صنفطه تقارير رسميه دوليه بالاكثر دمويه
منذ عام 2006 ويرى الفلسطينيون ان القادم
يبدو اكثر فتكا مع ملامح تشكيلي الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده
من بلده حوار جنوبيه بس